das ist einfach eine sensation gestern
sind gesteinsproben des mehr als 300
millionen kilometer entfernten
asteroiden ri jong mu auf die erde
gestürzt um 2 uhr 30 ortszeit waren die
proben in einer kapsel auf dem
australischen kontinent gelandet in dem
gestein soll jetzt nach organischen
verbindungen und wasser gesucht werden
beides könnte das leben in unserem
sonnensystem besser erklären und die
mission ist noch lange nicht vorbei
klicks um science im future die zweimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
herzlich willkommen
pixum sunsim future gibt es übrigens
auch als podcast die links spotify und
apple sind unten in der video
beschreibung und hier und da ja und das
ist wirklich ein irrsinniges projekt wir
haben ja schon x-mal darüber berichtet
das ganze begann mit einer weltpremiere
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
menschheit wurde ein asteroid von einem
raum fahrzeug aus beschossen
das künstliche loch das asteroiden
entstanden zwar schon im letzten jahr
2019 und jetzt sind die dabei
entnommenen gesteinsproben endlich auf
der erde angekommen und zwar ein
höllenritt am 15 april 2009 10 beschoss
ein japanisches forschungsteam den
gigantischen brocken mit hilfe der
raumsonde hayabusa 2 auf deutsch
wanderfalke 2 und einer etwa
tennisballgroßen und zwei kilogramm
schweren kupfer scheibe diese rasse mit
rund 7200 kilometern pro stunde durch
den weltraum und schlug auf hugo 1
benannt ist ruhiger übrigens nach dem
ort einer japanischen legende in der ein
fischer mit einem schatz voller
geheimnisse aus dem palast des drachen
königs zurückkehrt dieses bonmot 2009 10
wurde auch von der raumsonde hayabusa
zwei gefilmt so entstand also der krater
in der oberfläche des geröll körpers ist
etwa 950 meter groß etwa 325 millionen
kilometer von der erde entfernt und
befindet sich auf der umlaufbahn
zwischen mars und erde also nicht im
asteroidengürtel
der künstliche katar hat die form eines
halbkreises und ist mit einem
durchmesser von 18 metern deutlich
größer als erwartet was schon viel über
den asteroiden aus sagt die form und die
größe des künstlich
sollten kraters verraten viel über die
zusammensetzung von hugo und schon aus
der ferne hatte rio geheimnisse der
proben gelüftet seine oberfläche besteht
demnach wohl aus porösem material wie
geröll und sand zudem legen form und
größe des kraters nahe dass ein
felsbrocken offenbar einen teil der wird
abgefangen hat heißt also dass das
projektil auf einen größeren gerolstein
getroffen war so entstand also die
ungleichmäßige form die aufgewirbelte
staubwolke die bei dem aufprall entstand
offenbart den vorstellen dass jogi wohl
hauptsächlich aus feinkörnigem gestein
besteht und eben kein staub das
bombardement verrät zudem dass das
innere des asteroiden aus einem anderen
material besteht als seine oberfläche
dieses sand artigen gestein der
oberfläche wird wohl nur durch die
schwache schwerkraft des asteroiden
zusammengehalten und ist wohl nur neun
millionen jahre alt im vergleich zum
rest des astrium bislang ging man in der
fachwelt von einem deutlich höheren
alter aus nämlich rund 100 millionen
jahre
das ist ein krasses ergebnis ruge ist
also viel jünger als gedacht quasi
blutjung die auswertung der daten
offenbarten noch weitere super
spektakuläre erkenntnisse und die lassen
das japanische forschungsteam tief in
die evolution von hugo schauen anders
als vergleichbare planetoiden handelte
sich bei diesem also eben wohl um einen
kohlenstoffhaltigen körper aus der
frühzeit des sonnensystems solche
sogenannten typ c asteroiden sind mit
den kollegen kontrollierten vergleichbar
damit gemeint ist urtümliches gestein
aus dem sich vor rund 4,5 milliarden
jahren wohl auch die erde gebildet hat
genau deswegen sind die jetzt geborgen
gesteinsproben auch so besonders
spannend für die wissenschaft der man
erhofft sich mit ihrer hilfe die
planetenentstehung im sonnensystem zu
verstehen das problem dabei solche
konkreten schaffen es meistens nicht auf
die erdoberfläche
da sie bei eintritt in die erdatmosphäre
verglühen deswegen ist ihre
physikalische beschaffenheit
weitestgehend unbekannt wegen seiner
größe gehört aber trotzdem zu dem
potenziell gefährlich nahe zu liegen und
wird deshalb auch so genau unter die
lupe genommen
denn nichts genaues weiß man nicht
wahrscheinlich ist ruh ungefährlich aber
vielleicht auch eben nicht genau das und
noch einiges über die entstehung unseres
sonnensystems sollte hayabusa 2
ermitteln
noch sind aber die auswertung nicht im
entferntesten abgeschlossen
schon 2014 war die raumsonde hayabusa 2
gestartet eine absolut spektakuläre
mission vollgepackt mit technik
insgesamt vier sonden waren an bord
deren landung auf dem asteroiden
vorgesehen war alle voller sensoren
kameras und weiterem equipment 123
millionen euro kostete die mission der
japanischen raumfahrtagentur jaxa mit
beteiligung des deutschen zentrums für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr und der
französischen raumfahrtagentur cnrs ende
juni 2018 hatte sie dann erzielt fast
erreicht den asteroiden ru
die japanische raumfahrtagentur jaxa
meldete dass die sonne sich nun 20
kilometer von rio gruppe finden und von
dort aus messungen vornehmen werde das
ganze spielt sich eben rund 300
millionen kilometer von uns entfernt
habe aber ist nicht immer so weit weg
manchmal ist der asteroid auch näher
er befindet sich auf einer umlaufbahn um
die sonne die die der erde kreuzt damit
gehört dazu dem potenziell gefährlichen
asteroiden die auf der erde einschlagen
können und diese mission hat das ziel
mehr über diese asteroiden klasse zu
erfahren hayabusa 2 hat den asteroiden
anderthalb jahre vermessen zudem hat die
sonde zwei container abgesetzt in den
rover verstaut waren
mit einem wurden die rover 1a und 1b
abgesetzt sie waren in einem gemeinsamen
container transportiert worden und sind
gleich gebaut wiegen jeweils etwas mehr
als ein kilo und sind als zylinder
ausgelegt mit sieben zentimeter höhe und
18 zentimeter durchmesser haben sie also
die form jeweils einer dicken scheibe
sie enthalten beide jeweils eine
stereokamera eine weitwinkel kamera und
ein thermometer die energieversorgung
basiert auf solarzellen und
superkondensatoren der rover 2 wurde im
zweiten container minerva zwei
transportiert er wiegt rund ein
kilogramm und ist achteckig 15
zentimeter durchmesser und 16 zentimeter
höhe
zwei kameras ein thermometer und ein
beschleunigungssensor gehört zu seiner
ausrüstung und leds im optischen und
uv-licht bereich um aufgewirbelte
partikel zu beleuchten over 2 wird
ebenfalls mit solarzellen mit energie
versorgt und im oktober 2018 hatte das
landemodul mobile adserver scout kurz
mask und erste aufnahmen der asteroiden
oberfläche an die erde gesendet
dabei nahm die kamera mesken bereits
während des abstiegs bilder auf nach der
landung hat
sind die umgebung der landesstelle bis
zum horizont in hoher auflösung
fotografiert und auf der asteroiden
oberfläche biologische und physikalische
messung der umgebung und des
untergrundes durchgeführt übrigens wurde
die eingesetzte kamera mesz camp vom
deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr in köln entwickelt das
radiometer mara hat die
oberflächentemperatur sowie die
thermischen eigenschaften des
oberflächen materials gemessen
das infrarotspektrum mikroskop micro
omega ein instrument das institut
d'astrophysique spezial paris hat die
mineralogische zusammensetzung der
oberfläche ermittelt und das
magnetometer mac eine entwicklung des
instituts für geophysik und
extraterrestrische physik der
technischen universität braunschweig hat
das magnetfeld des asteroiden vermessen
ein heftiges programm
das hat mascotte an verschiedenen orten
gemacht dabei hat sich der board mit
einem schwung nahmen von ort zu ort
bewegt die gravitation die schwache
gravitation des asteroiden ist eben so
schwach dass bei jeder anderen
fortbewegung die gefahr bestünde vom
asteroiden wegzufliegen überwacht wurde
das zehn kilogramm schwere gerät von
köln aus rund 17 stunden hatte mascotte
während des abstiegs des länder zeit um
die umgebung aus nächster nähe zu
fotografieren astronomie team aus berlin
hatte die bilder detailliert ausgewertet
die bilder zeigen das logo aus
mindestens vier verschiedenen
gesteinsarten besteht die helleren
bruchstücke haben er glatte kanten und
oberflächen die dunkle und broken
dagegen erscheinen unregelmäßiger in
ihrer form ein bisschen erinnern sie an
die form eines blumen kohls in der
gestalt matrix eines dunklen felsen sind
helle ansprechende zu erkennen manche
dieser mineral körner sind knapp 1 cm
groß zwei verschiedene farben der
einschüsse sind erkennbar nach vermutung
der fachleute handelt es sich bei
manchen der hellen generale um das
silikate olivin es kann sowohl im
basischen als auch in sauren
magnetischen gesteinen entstehen und hat
einen hohen schmelzpunkt auf unserer
erde lässt sich uni wien unter anderem
an einigen orten der eifel und dem
siebengebirge in italien und
beispielsweise auch in österreich
norwegen und auf hawaii finden doch
warum setzt sich das solid aus
verschiedenen gesteinstypen zusammen
fachleute haben auf diese frage noch
keine eindeutige antwort eine mögliche
erklärung könnte sein dass jude aus zwei
vorläufer objekten entstanden
die miteinander kollidiert sind
möglicherweise ist der erdgas zu ihnen
aber auch auf eine andere art und weise
entstanden nämlich durch die ansammlung
mehrerer trümmer diese könnten sich in
den anfängen des sonnensystems aus einem
deutlich größeren himmelskörper gebildet
haben zudem weisen gefüllten krater
erdrutsche und ein speckgürtel um logos
äquator darauf hin dass er sich in
früheren zeiten einmal schneller um
seine eigene achse gedreht haben muss
als es derzeit der fall ist
zusammengefasst bei priogo handelt es
sich um einen gruseligen brocken und das
ist eine enorm wichtige erkenntnis dazu
ralf jaumann vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt würde oder ein
ähnliches zu der erde einmal gefährlich
nahe kommen und wir müssen versuchen ihn
abzulenken
dann sollten wir sehr vorsichtig mit ihm
umgehen denn wenn wir zu fest auf ihn
drauf hauen zerfällt der ganze eine
halbe milliarde tonnen schwere assault
in unzählige bruchstücke dann prasseln
lauter tonnenschwere einzelteile auf die
erde tatsächlich kommt roux der erdbahn
ziemlich nahe seine bahn verläuft
parallel zu ihr und ernährt sich bis auf
eine distanz von rund 100.000 kilometern
allerdings mit einer geringen neigung
eine kollision ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich die analyse der bilder
hat zudem weitere details zu der
zusammensetzung von hugo offengelegt
wasser gibt es auf dem asteroiden
demnach nur in spuren denn sonst hätten
sich die minerale im gestein nach
ansicht des forschungsteams längst
verändern müssen
das forschungsteam hat dafür bislang
keine erklärung denn eigentlich müsste
staub aufgrund des beschlusses des
asteroiden mit mikrometeoriten ja zu
finden seien möglicherweise ist der
staub ins all entwickeln bedingt durch
die geringe schwerkraft von nur einem 60
tausendstel der erde oder aber er ist
einfach in hohlräumen verschwunden davon
gibt es wohl einige zumindest les
rousses geringe dichte von
durchschnittlich 1,2 gramm pro
kubikmeter darauf schließen dazu das
forschungsteam aus berlin in einer
studie
dies gibt einen hinweis auf komplexe
geophysikalische prozesse auf der
oberfläche dieses kleinen tasten und
eine weitere erkenntnis dazu ist das der
erdmasse wo zu den dunkelsten objekten
im sonnensystem gehört denn er
reflektiert lediglich 4,5 des
sonnenlichts was da am wochenende
geschah war absolut spektakulär hayabusa
zwei stürze
nämlich nicht selbst auf die erde
sondern setzte eine kapsel
beim vorbeiflug an der erde ab
mitarbeitende orteten dann die kapsel
mittels peilsender im landegebiet in
australien auf die ergebnisse der
untersuchung der gesteinsproben müssen
wir aber wohl noch etwas warten erst mal
werden die proben nur angeguckt
tatsächlich werden sie zunächst genau
visuell untersucht und katalogisiert und
diese arbeit wird wohl etwas kleinteilig
im wahrsten sinne des wortes hayabusa 2
hat nämlich 0,1 gramm proben gesammelt
sprich ein paar körner
ich habe das mal hier auf eine
briefwaage mit grease nachgestellt das
ist ein gramm also im vergleich zur eu
also ungefähr nur ein zehntel und erst
mitte nächsten jahres 2021 sollen diese
minimale menge chemische und
mineralogische untersucht werden und
anders als die erste abuja sonde die
beim eintritt in die erdatmosphäre
verglüht war
fliegt hayabusa zwei jetzt weiter ihr
ziel der erdnahe asteroiden 1998 kyoto-2
1027 macht sie aber noch
zwischenstationen am asteroiden 2001 cc
21 nach zwei ist wegen bei manövern an
der erde geht es dann weiter zu 1998 kai
10 26 denen sie im juli 2000 31
erreichen wird eine wirklich ziemlich
spektakuläre mission eine sonde die
probenmaterial auf der erde abwirft um
dann ihre mission fortzusetzen das gab
es so noch nie asteroiden mit kurs auf
die erde erste planetare verteidigungs
mission gestartet das ist auch ziemlich
spektakulär also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar diesen kanal
kriegstanz in future bis dann bleibt
dran